are you i'm great how are you doing i'm
doing very well i'm doing very well yeah
my wife is i mean we're both fans of
your show but my wife freaked out today
when she found out you were on the
program oh yeah is she all right i know
she's
she's in the hospital now and it's
it's all your fault feel terrible yeah
yeah she has what's called a girl crush
on you oh that's cool she's a fan yeah
she's a huge fan she's gonna have a girl
crush on her and i said it's getting
weird
and i thought about it i thought that's
cool yeah
well there's so much to talk about
you're you know you're a very impressive
person because i was reading your bio
today and it was about how spanish is
your first language you're fluent in
spanish it is my first language yeah i
grew up
speaking spanish and i learned english
in school
and um
and i had a lot of you know most people
don't realize that i speak spanish
because i look very
white yeah so um
so so it's sort of like a secret that
you're fluent in spanish
yeah when i was a kid i remember like um
like for instance going to get a haircut
and um and you know the ladies would be
speaking in spanish behind me and mine
would say um the lady cutting my hair
would say oh i just took like a big
chunk out of her hair and and oh and the
other one's like well just just tuck it
in there she'll never notice like
they're saying this wow there you go i'm
like oh no i'm like seven years old and
my eyes like bug out in my head i'm like
well crap that's terrible like um so she
didn't get a tip which
he should have just said at the end
i know i should have really gotten her
with something i just didn't know what
to do yeah now you've been you like to
travel because
uh i mean i like to travel too but we
don't really ever get that much time off
consecutively on a show like this to
really go anywhere right but you you can
sometimes get like a month or two months
where you're not working where do you
like to go um well i love going to
europe one of my favorite trips was
actually to um to tuscany with my friend
beautiful oh it's so beautiful and we
took a cooking class
there and we learned all kinds of stuff
but mostly we just ate all the delicious
food and
that was my that's why i went basically
because the deal was if you cook it you
get to eat it and it was like five meals
a day or five yeah five courses
basically to each meal so um so it was
just a blast i mean would you say that's
your favorite cuisine italian
i love i love all kinds of cuisine but i
love everything from like gourmet stuff
to like wendy's chicken nuggets like the
99 cent five piece chicken nuggets wow
uh tell us
tell us more
they're delicious
have you ever had them i have you know
i'm trying to think if i've had wendy's
chicken i know i don't think so i don't
think i've had their chicken nuggets
what makes their chicken nuggets say
superior to mcdonald's or burger king
they're very crispy and then and then
they you know they're all like white
white meat and they have like different
sauces and i've mcdonald's has different
sauces not the same not the same what's
different about these sauces they're
just better they're like barbecue
barbecue is like the best one and they
als wendy's offers um hi-c
spicy fruit punch
you get a hi-c fruit that's like the
perfect chaser for uh for a wendy's
chicken nugget so you what cause the the
flavors complement each other it's
wonderful this is incredible uh jeff
is wendy's a sponsor for us or is it who
is they might as who is who's our
sponsor oh we're so screwed
oh no see i disagree
i prefer mcdonald's yeah
because it's just better
wow that's frightening
i'm a little uncomfortable
the grimace is going to be waiting by my
car tonight
beat the crap out of me
and then throw a shake at my head it
doesn't happen again see
and then the cheese will be there yeah
that better not happen again
sorry about it
[Applause]
i totally believe what you're saying
though i once got hooked on i'm just
going for it i got hooked once kentucky
fried chicken a couple years ago was
making this extra crispy chicken
sandwich
and for some reason i had one at a kfc
that's like up on 130th street under an
iron bridge and i was i was going there
late at night like i was going to buy
heroin but i was going up there
and i'd hit really fast and then i'd see
like some police cars and i'd run away
i know exactly what you're talking about
that's what it comes to sometimes i
don't know
well i'm not going to promote the movie
ladies and gentlemen wendy's
check it out wendy's chicken strips
let me ask you one thing i it's
something i'm a little curious about
you're 24 years old yeah and this is a
compliment you you you look much younger
but i don't know if that's hard for you
it's hard sometimes it's you know you
get carded a lot when you go to a bar or
a club or something but um
but no i mean
the weirdest thing about it is when
you're working and you know you're going
to play like an 18 year old in a movie
sometimes your co-star is actually like
17 or 18 and you have to make out with
this person but i'm 24. and i you know i
i feel that that's wrong
honestly
i feel like it's very wrong especially
when it's on the cusp but like 18 not
quite right
sure i feel weird about it all right kid
let's do this
you kids you don't know what it's like
no you're so innocent but you get hooked
on those wendy's nuggets
it's all downhill